c'est l'un des points stratégiques pour
le groupe safran basculer vers l'avion
vert pour cela safran va investir 4
milliards d'euros entre 2021 et 2025
trois quarts de sa terme à this man va
être accordée à la décarbonation de
l'avion pour en parler nous sommes avec
le directeur de s'affronter que vincent
garnier bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors s'affrontaient qu'est ce que c'est
alors ça frontex et le centre de
recherche mutualisé du groupe safran
nous travaillons au sein du centre de
recherche sur un certain nombre de
thématiques transverses à l'ensemble des
sociétés du groupe safran et l'objectif
est de travailler sur les nouvelles
technologies qui vont précisément être
intégré dans l'avion vers à l'horizon de
2035 le centre de recherche là dedans
est un élément clé qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver un avion vers qu'est-ce que
safran va pouvoir y apporter d'abord un
moteur beaucoup plus performants que les
moteurs même ceux qui viennent d'entrer
en service ou savez peut-être safran a
fait rentrer en service récemment un
nouveau moteur qui fait un gain de
carburant de 15% par rapport aux avions
qui volent en majorité dans la flotte
actuelle et nous prévoyons d'ici 2035 de
faire entrer en service un nouveau type
de moteur et ce nouveau type de moteur
nous préparons de nous commençons de
préparer dès aujourd'hui ça fait l'objet
d'un programme de recherche et
technologie que nous avons annoncés ici
même à magny les hameaux il ya un peu
plus d'un an maintenant le directeur
général du groupe l'a fait lui-même pour
vous dire l'importance que ce programme
revêt pour le groupe et donc c'est le
premier élément vraiment de l'avion vers
vue de sa france et ce moteur qui va
faire bénéficier l'avion qu'il portera
de 20 % de gain de consommation
supplémentaire par rapport à la
référence déjà extrêmement performante
qui est le moteur leap on va travailler
également dans l'avion vers sur le fait
d'aller j'ai tous les équipements et là
c'est vraiment des thématiques de type
matériaux beaucoup plus performant
beaucoup plus robuste beaucoup plus
léger qui vont permettre à l'ensemble
des équipements du groupe d'être ré
redimensionner vraiment réexaminée dans
leur au plus profond d'eux-mêmes pour
pouvoir faire alléger l'avion qui va les
porter finalement y'a pas que le facteur
énergie parce que quand on entend parler
d'environnement parle souvent d'énergies
renouvelables finalement vous vous ne
semblez pas uniquement le facteur
énergie
alors on fait tout ce qu'on va faire on
va
aller dans le sens d'améliorer
l'efficacité vraiment du système de
transport aérien j'ai parlé du moteur
j'ai parlé de l'allègement il faut
savoir qu'un autre pilier de la
décarbonation du transport aérien
puisque le transport aérien vise vous le
savez d'être neutre en carbone à
l'horizon 2050 l'autre pilier de cette
transformation c'est la mise à
disposition de carburant à d'aviation
durable et donc le nous dans le cadre de
l'avion vers nous travaillons ce que
toutes les technologies que nous
proposons puisse être compatible avec
ces carburants durables nous en parler
du carburant justement mais vous êtes
engagé aussi dans le verdissement du
carburant à travers le développement du
bio carburant et vous avez passé un
partenariat avec total énergie qu'est ce
que vous faites chez safran tech par
rapport aux biocarburants alors on
étudie dans le biocarburant fait quelles
pourraient être ces meilleures
propriétés ça ça ça paraît peut-être un
peu étrange mais aujourd'hui les
carburants qui sont utilisés dans
l'aéronautique sont sont le kérosène qui
est un dérivé bien sûr du pétrole tout à
fait classique c'est un très très bon
carburant sens que il est parfaitement
stable il peut être utilisé dans plein
de conditions les plus extrêmes c'est un
vraiment à carburant un peu rêvé pour
l'hérault nautique et on cherche à
reproduire ses excellentes
caractéristiques avec du carburant qu'on
appelle de synthèse des tissus des bio
de la biomasse par exemple et donc on se
demande si en utilisant dès le départ
une source comme la biomasse on ne peut
pas construire un carburant encore
meilleur que le kérosène un carburant
qui émettra encore moins de dérivés
deux types particules par exemple un
carburant qui permettra de mieux
maîtriser les émissions de dioxyde
d'azoté voilà et donc ça fait partie des
recherches que nous menons effectivement
avec total dans l'étape de ce
partenariat et dans le cadre également
de gros projets de recherche qui sont ce
qu'ils sont soutenus par la dg assez
pour comprendre quels sont les meilleurs
ingrédients d'un carburants durables
pour l'aéronautique à l'horizon des
prochaines années puisque l'ambition de
l'ensemble de l'industrie c'est bien de
faire monter ses carburants en volume et
petit à petit de complètement remplacer
les carburants d'origine fossile par ces
carburants durables et dans toutes ces
erreurs charge vous êtes soutenus par
l'état puisque l'avion vers c'est un des
programmes du plan france relance 1.5
milliards d'euros sur trois ans investi
par l'état
qu'est-ce que vous avez quel parti vous
avez bénéficié vous avez bénéficié de
combien chez safran alors le plan de
relance il est venu déjà à point nommé
on a mentionné cette fameuse crise
sanitaire tout à l'heure vraiment il
nous a permis de rebondir jeu j'ai
utilisé le terme c'est un des
ingrédients qui nous a permis de
rebondir très fortement et au total il
se développe sur
2020 2024 on a commencé à signer des
contrats de subvention avec l'état en
2020 et on va finir on va signer les
derniers contrats ici en 2022 début 2022
pour une activité qui va se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2024 pour sa france et
représente sans doute une centaine de
projets et une subvention de l'ordre de
400 440 millions d'euros donc vraiment
une subvention très substantiels dont
que nous utilisons comme un effet levier
puisque safran au fur et à mesure que
l'industrie ont rebondi que notre
activité repart que notre profitabilité
s'améliore a décidé d'investir ses
propres ressources pour accompagner bien
sûr ce plan de relance pour bénéficier
de l'effet multiplicateur
et c'est ce qui donne en finale ce
fameux 4 milliards que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure sur cinq ans pour aller
développer les technologies comme le
moteur à risque comme les allègements
comme l'électrification des activités
qui sont présentes d'ici six à magny les
hameaux mais mise à part la
décarbonation de l'avion il y à d'autres
sujets aussi je crois savoir qu on
pourrait peut-être voir des systèmes
autonomes dans les aéronefs au sol pour
bien rassuré tout le monde sait bien où
cela l'utilisation des aéronefs au sol
c'est une partie importante de la de
bien sûr de leur fiabilité de l'au delà
de l'efficacité du système on évoquait
ce soit tout à l'heure le transport
aérien est une machine extrêmement
efficace et elle se renforce tous les
jours cette efficacité donc une idée
qu'on a eu pour combiner l'efficacité
énergétique et l'efficacité tout
simplement de l'organisation c'est
d'électrifier les avions au sol c'est à
vous parliez tout à l'heure de à quel
moment de la mission en avion peut-il
être électrifiée bien son taxing comme
on dit au sol c'est un c'est une phase
très importante qui consomment plusieurs
pourcents d'ailleurs de l'énergie qui
utilisent un avion dans son dans sa
mission faut le savoir donc une des
choses qu'on fait c'est travailler sur
ce taxiing électrique une autre chose
qu'on fait c'est essayer d'optimiser la
façon dont l'avion est menée dans ces
phases là et donc on s'est dit au fond
pourquoi ne pas appliquer pour cette
phase de taxi une démarche de type
autonomie tel qu'on peut le voir
aujourd'hui sur des véhicules terrestres
parce que les les équipages ont besoin d
aide sur cette phase là qui sont souvent
compliquées il faut aller s'insérer dans
un mine de rien dans un trafic qui peut
être assez serré dans un aéroport et
donc on s'est dit avec les équipements
du groupe safran ce qu on est ce qu'on
essaie ici dans un laboratoire a
effectivement d'autonomie que nous
partageons avec valéo estelle antilles
c'est une très belle démarche de
recherche collaboratifs que nous avons
menées ici que nous menons toujours on
met au point des systèmes autonomes des
capteurs des algorithmes et puis on
teste tout ça dans des véhicules
terrestres qu'on fait tourner autour du
site ici on a on a
digitalisées l'ensemble de saint quentin
en yvelines pour faire circuler des
véhicules et on applique ça dans le
domaine aéronautique a une idée de faire
du thaksin autonome et puis nous
également safran dans le domaine
militaire puisqu'on avait également une
activité de défense des équipements de
défense terrestre merci vincent garnier
merci je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de safran tech